so i i want to start i've been curious
about this and i want to start the
interview with this uh first of all
congrats on the movie fan of your work
great to talk to you um what was it like
actually telling your parents that you
wanted to be an actor
oh gosh
um
well i didn't really ever directly tell
them
i
i i loved uh
performing i was always putting on plays
when i was little and
um and then i started doing ballet at a
very young age and i think that was sort
of my indirect route towards acting
it's another way of
telling stories and um
and so i never really
said it out loud and i just kept
uh i just kept doing it and then
um
[Music]
yeah as i got like
into high school i started
doing the school plays and then by the
time i was applying to colleges i
i loved writing and i loved english and
then i also was looking at schools um
with theater programs and
anyway my parents were
were massively supportive but they
definitely
felt like i had found it
on on my own um
i've spoken to a number of actors with
uh parents that are in the industry and
they always i've heard about the talk
you know be prepared that you are you
know it's a real challenge stuff i was
just curious if you had ever gotten the
call there were lots of talks about like
don't do that don't don't be an actor
like do anything but this
um
[Music]
but anyway clearly these are you know
clearly all those warnings end up being
very futile
yeah i mean
if you want to do something you're going
to do it but um so i'm curious what was
it like actually i'm a big fan of
william monahan and his uh writing um so
i'm just curious what was it like
reading the script for the first time
and seeing his words on the page
i loved the script so much it had
there's so much um
there's so much restraint in the script
there's also the way that he writes
dialogue the language is so
beautiful and um
coming from the theater i'm someone who
you know i always lean in towards
towards language and when
um
[Music]
you get to have
these sort of
remarkably wonderful words and i he's
he's such a
he's such an amazing writer and then the
the novel is is also just
tremendously written
so
being so i mean listen writing as i say
as i was saying it was sort of my other
love and i'm the daughter of a writer
and um
being surrounded on both sides by such
incredible writing with this project was
certainly such a pull towards um
wanting to do it
sure it also doesn't you know hurt with
ben and george and all the other you
know but so i'm obviously a huge fan of
george clooney as well and i think he's
so talented behind the camera what maybe
surprised you about working with him
that perhaps you weren't expecting
i just think that you know the biggest
surprise was i knew that i would
i anticipated that i would love him but
i never could have imagined how much
i would love him um
both as a human being and as a director
it just uh exceeded all of my
expectations sort of on day one
um and i had a high bar set and he just
um
but he's he's such a trusting director i
think he's someone he trusts his actors
he trusts his choices so he's surrounded
himself by people you know his producing
partner is someone they've known each
other for years and they are so locked
in there's so much trust there and then
he has that for his crew he has that for
his actors so
um
you really
feel that on his set and i think he also
is very trusting of his audience i think
he's made a movie where he's not trying
to control the audience experience he's
really
generously gifting the film
to audiences and and knowing that
they'll have
their own very personal experience with
it
on how many days did it take for you to
become chris farley on set and start
geeking out with christopher lloyd
i'm i'm sort of
always pretty
nerdy but i'm also
shy
um so i don't know if i ever if i ever
did that overtly
um but it was so
you know it was so wonderful to
be on set with
with him because he's such a he's such
an amazing actor and
um
gosh there were lots of great stories
too on that set so i loved being around
those
yeah i can't even imagine it would be um
anyway so i'm a big fan of learning
about how the way the way actors prepare
for big scenes uh and you know just the
behind the scenes so hypothetically if
you have like a huge scene on a monday
you know it's going to be tough
emotionally draining whatever it may be
can you sort of talk to take me through
how you're getting ready for that scene
is it like a week out that you're
already working on it maybe could you
share your process
um
gosh
i i i think you start preparing or i
start preparing
from the moment i read the script or the
moment i know i'm going to do
um the job and there was something i
felt such a
something about
her
hit me
so personally and hit me at a moment in
my life where
uh it felt
very much like meeting a part
at a very specific point in time
um
that felt
very meant to be and
[Music]
so i think
you know if you have a
listen there are no small scenes and
also a scene that is
being emotionally drained i there's
nothing better than leaving
a day of work and feeling um
like you don't really have anything left
i i don't mind days like that
uh that's such a gift of getting to do
what i get to do which is
holding nothing nothing back for myself
just sort of
being able to um
hopefully give it all on on the on the
day so
i look forward to every day but i
certainly look forward to those days uh
i did not know
i watched the movie and then learned
about daniel's um video the uh i know i
didn't know until i got on set and
george
you know pulled it up on his phone for
me
what was your reaction when you saw it
and then working with him well it was so
it was so great and you know his that's
his mother his mother plays
my sister
uh in that she's the one who knocks over
the radio that's his that's his mother
um
and so seeing the two of them
uh in that video was so
it was so
delicious it was
like and he's so uh he's just fearless
and that's how he is
as an actor that's how he is
um
[Music]
on set he walked into this
what could have been i'm sure an
incredibly intimidating
environment and he just
had such
um
self-possession and he really
he was just present and everything you
could want in a in a scene partner and
he was so easy to fall in love with
uh i got to go but i am looking forward
to love and death on hbo max oh good
thank you
i'm assuming you're filming
i am
right
i won't pressure you on that thing um
i'll just say congrats on everything
great talking with you and i hope that's
a huge hit
thank you so much thank you
you